πτο ιβλίων του και να τις θέσεις το γραπτών τους τις εξετάσεις του και να
πάει παρακάτω και να τα ξεχάσεις ως μετα άρά το στίχημα που είναι να αλλάξω
τα ναλυτικά προγράμματα να τα επικαιροποιήσουμε όπως λέμε α τα εξιχρονίσουμε αρχίσαμε αυτό το τεράστιο
βήμα πμε να αρκετά καλά υπάρχουν τεράστηριες προκλήσεις και αυτές είναι κυρίως οι αντίσταση στην
αλλαγή έχουμε βολευτίμ αυτά που κάναμε γαι απο λά χρόνια όλοι πρέπει όμως να ξεβολευτούμε
να σ ουμε επιτραπή αυτός ώρος πρέπει να κάνουμε το επόμενο βήμα και για να
μπορέσουν όλοι να το κάμου πρέπει να παρακολουθούνται καια να ξιολογούνται άρα δεύτερι πρόκληση ίναι
αξιολόγηση των εκπαιδευτικό ο πρώετος δημοκρατίας πρήλιγας μέρα σήπενω ότι ίνγια το η κόρη είχε
αντιδράσεις για την απαγόρεση των κινητώ εσας και ήταν το πρώτον άτομο που σας είπε
γιατί να γίνει αυτόνα είναι τα παιδιά τις οικογένειας όπως δήποτε με τηλεφωνήματα μητο κάνεισε
αυτό αφίστε μας να το χρησιμοποιούμε σήμερα όμως δύο τρεις δομάδες μετά από πέρασε τη
νομοθεσία χαίρομε παρά πολύ που παίρνου και μηνύματα από εκπαιδευτικούς θέλουμε μου υπεκτές έχω το
μήνυμα μιας κυρίας είναι μουσικό σεσχολείο χαίρομε που πέρασε εντελικά υτή νομοθεσία ελάται να δείται
τι γίνεται το διάλημα μιλούν μεταξύτους λέω πάναγεία μου ταν τόσο σοβαρό μιλούν μεταξύ τους
και μάλιστα προσεγγίζουν κια τα παιδιά που ήταν από μονομένα γιατί ήταν πάνω στο τηλέφωνο
τους ακόμα και εφαινόμενα που ήταν ακραέα αυτή τις στιγμή με την κατάλληλ βέβαια παιδονομία
και των έλεγχον από τους εκπαιδευτικούς μας μπορούμε να τα να τα αποτρέψουμε είμαστε εδώ
είπαμε ότι αυτή χρονια θα θα είναι παιδαγωγικής φίσις τα μέτρα θα είμαστε κοντά στα
παιδιά θα μιλούμε αντιλαμβάνουμε πλήρος και εγώ θέλω το κινητών μου καθετώσον να το δώ
να το να ελέγξω τι γίνεται παρόλα αυτά τα βοηθούμε τα παιδιά δεν τατ